[Music]
the eyes to the right 322 the nose to
the left
306
[Applause]
thank you
the eyes to the right 322 the nose to
the left 306 so the eyes have it the
eyes have it unlocked
[Music]
I'm very grateful to you I'm very
grateful to every to the House of
Commons staff everybody who's put
themselves out everybody who's come to
give up their time in this debate today
it's been a very important debate and
exceptional moment for our country
except a moment for our Parliament alas
the opportunity to have a meaningful
vote has effectively been passed up
because the meaningful vote has been
voided of meaning but I wish the house
to know that I'm not daunted or dismayed
by this particular result became likely
once it was obvious that the amendment
for me my right honourable friend the
member of West Dorset was going to
remain on the order paper I continued in
the very strong belief that the best
thing for the UK and for the whole of
Europe is for us to leave with this new
deal on October to anticipate the
questions that are coming from their
benches of it I will not negotiate a
delay with the EU
[Applause]
and neither does the law compel me to do
so I will tell our friends and
colleagues in the EU exactly what I have
told everyone in the last 88 days that
I've served as Prime Minister but
further that they would be bad for this
country
[Applause]
and bad for democracy so next week the
government will introduce the
legislation needed for us to leave the
EU with our new deal on October the
30-person I hope I hope that our
European Union colleagues and friends
will not be attracted as as benches
opposite are or rather I should say the
front bench is by delay I don't think
they'll be attracted by the May and I
hope that then honourable members faced
with a choice of our New Deal our New
Deal for the UK and the European Union
will change their minds because it was
pretty close today I hope that they will
change I hope that they will change
their minds and support this deal in
overwhelming numbers since I became
Prime Minister I've said we must get on
and get brexit done on October the 31st
so that this country can move on mr.
speaker that policy that policy remains
unchanged no delays and I will continue
to do all I can to get breaks it done on
October the 31st and I continue to
commend this excellent deal mr. speaker
to the house
[Applause]